[موسيقى]
طبيعي انه يكون في حاجز على البوابه وضع
طبيعي انه يكون في جيش هذا يعني شبه يومي
بكون موجود
بحكم وجود البيت قريب من البرج والبوابه
متعايش مع الموضوع طبيعي انه انا بكون
مارس حياتي عاديه يعني بدخل على البيت
بطلع على البيت
اللي صار كالتالي انه هم كانوا حاطين حاجز
ويعني اعاقوا الناس كثير اعاقل طالع على
رام الله كان من المنطقه عنا بطريقه مش
طبيعيه
فاضطروا انه يعني يحاولوا يقمعوا التجمع
الناس الكثير
رده فعلهم كانت يعني مش طبيعيه حاولوا
يعني تجيبوا جيش كميه عدد جيش كثيره
ودخلوا جيب بيت كمان انهم يحاولوا ينظموا
الخط للسير
طبعا هم كان روايه انه انطخ عليهم يعني
كان في اطلاق نار لكن هذا الحكي يعني انا
شخصيا ما سمعته لاني كنت متواجد طيله
الوقت هنيك
[موسيقى]
قررت اطلع من البيت
اتجاه يعني دار عمي الي
فحركت السياره مع مع الولد ركبته في
السياره وطلعت
مباشره اول ما تحركت السياره ودوت
ضربوا عليها رصاص
الرصاص اجا في السياره اول اشي
ويعني كان في شعور بانه السيارات الا اني
انا يعني
رديت رجعت السياره كمان شوي بس ردوا ضربه
عليها انا ما شعرت اني تصوبت
بس الكزاز السياره تكسر واجي علي
فالتفت وراي على الولد انه الولد مصاب
يعني مصاب واك على كرسي السياره ورا
سياره سياره
الحمد لله
بسرعه بسرعه بسرعه بسرعه
مكملين طريقنا احنا على الاسعاف وصلنا
يعني وصلنا البوابه وصلنا البرج بس طبعا
هم يعني بما انه احنا تجاوزنا كل السيارات
واعطينا انه معنا حالي اشي معين
تهجموا على السياره ما ما استوعبوا انه
السياره توصل لهم بهاي الطريقه
تفاجانا بعد الجيش كبير لفه من وراء
السيارات يعني حوطوا كل السياره وساحبين
السلاح
في جند من الجنود شاف الولد شاف الولد لما
رفعوا له اياه الشباب اللي معي ورجوه
الولد انه مصاب والدم عليه
فاعطى الاشاره للجنود انه
يعني اصابه فسمحوا لنا انه نقطع الحاجز
وصلنا احنا المستوطنين كان يعني مساله وقت
بسيطه جتلي الاسعاف الفلسطينيه
وشخصت الحاله بانه حالتي يعني انا ممكن
تكون مستقره وياخذوني همي وحاله الولد
كانت يعني في نظرهم صعب فبالتالي يعني
قرروا ياخذوهم اليهود
[موسيقى]
اصابتي كانت في الكتف فراس فلسطين وحده حي
دخلته وخرجت من
الكتف
ورصاصه كانت دوم دوم تفجرت الشظايا في
الكتف توقعاتهم بانهم ما في مساله الوقت
والكفيل
بالعلاج وان شاء الله انه خير يعني الشوط
المرحله الاولى عدت مرحله الخطر العالي
[موسيقى]
حالنا حالا الشعب كله يعني ضحيه الحدث هو
قديم جديد يعني متكرر يعني انا البيت عندي
لو اسجل لك الاضرار اللي انصبت انصاب فيها
البيت يعني لا تحصى من شبابيك من حمام
شمسي من خزانات مي من ابواب رئيسيه حتى
لداخل البيت يتاثر الاساس باصابات هذا
يعني شبه يعني كان مع كل الاحداث تصير في
البلد يتكرر